on pourrait croire à un mauvais remake
d' harry potter made in télé réalité une
affaire sombre de sorcellerie au sein
des marseillais c'est un truc d'hommes
coiffés par emma est vague et même une
des candidats du programme de w9 qui
révèle l'information et accuse d'une de
ses amies de l' aventure d'avoir tenté
de lui jeter un sort je fais caca d'un
flash
on nous fait de la sorcellerie des
poupées vaudou en effet car la mort
aurait donné des instructions à sa
voyante via des notes vocales que le
blogueur marc platt a retrouvé en plus
de vouloir être la star du programme
elle demande à la voyante de faire en
sorte que le mariage d'une autre
candidate manon soit là encore annulés
s'il faut enlever le mariage de julien
mannon dans la prochaine saison et le
remplaçait par mois qui viennent on le
fait aussi
des révélations qui ont fait un tollé
dans le petit monde de la télé réalité
si carla n'a pas encore répondu à ces
accusations reste à espérer que le sort
ne se retourne pas contre elle
alors croyez vous aux accusations de
sorcellerie contre la candidate de télé
réalité car la mort aux marques plata et
en direct sur notre plateau ce soir pour
nous dévoiler d'autres informations
d'exclusivité marc batta blogueur ex
candidats de télé réalité qui sera avec
vous dans un instant en fait ce time qui
a donc jeté aux ordures apparemment à
nous faire partager juste autour de la
table avant qu'on ait samedi rats et
roland perez qui vont s'exprimer
là-dessus qui d'abord sam pour les
téléspectateurs connaissent pas 20 ans
sa conduite qui est accusé c'est donc
car l'amour au sénat candidate
emblématique de l'émission télé réalité
les marseillais c'est ça car l'amour ou
qu'on a tous découvert dans les
marseillais south africa ça fait
quelques années maintenant c'est devenu
un personnage culte mais au travers
notamment au départ de sa relation avec
kevin gages qui était et qui était près
sa raclée mais tu es très sympa adorable
bon il ya eu pas mal d'adultère de
tromperie qui ont été montrées à la
télévision est aussi dans la vraie vie
de l'autre côté c'est vrai qu'on l'a
connu pour ça et aujourd'hui elle se
retrouve dans la tourmente et on est
tous scotchés comme les personnes qui
ont pu travailler avec elle je vous en
dirai plus après cette histoire est
incroyable
depuis que l'affairé sortie car la mort
on ne sait donc pas exprimé non on a vu
fleurir ces dernières heures plusieurs
rumeurs concernant d'éventuelles
tentatives de suicide alors de quoi elle
est accusée
c'est faux les tentatives de suicide
maeva gainey en a parlé sur ces réseaux
sociaux il me l'a dit qu'elle s'était
entretenue donc avec son concubin qui
est des miettes
et il lui a confirmé qu'elle n'avait
fait aucune tentative de suicide il faut
faire attention aussi à ce qu'on peut
voir sur internet en tout cas où je vous
parle c'est des infos que j'ai alors
elle est accusée d'avoir eu recours à la
sorcellerie alors les téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoigne la ici les les
chroniqueurs les éditorialistes qui le
suivent dix mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire de fou parce que c'est
vrai que c'est alimenter les réseaux
sociaux toute la journée
ça a été un buzz incroyable tout le
monde attendait sujet ce soir
qu'est ce que c'est que cette affaire
deux sur sept eh ben elle est accusée ça
c'est un fait on peut pas le nier par
énormément de marceille et jusqu'à
junien tanti qui est le pilier quelque
part julien tanti c'est bien sûr le
personnage intouchable de l'émission
d'avoir fait de la sorcellerie au
travers d'une sorcière réputé à
marseille apparemment pour nuire à des
candidats pour faire annuler des
mariages prétextant vouloir être la star
la numéro une briet que la production ne
lui disent pas de se mettre avec intel
en couple ou autres donc ça veut dire
que c'est grave ça va jusqu'à mettre les
personnes qui travaillent avec elle dans
la sauce mais c'est incroyable parce que
on se dit voilà accusé de sorcellerie on
voit ça que dans les réalités de rue
libanaise
ça existe tout à fait ça s'appelle un
envoûtement de ruines
ça coûte de 5000 à 50000 euros qu'elle
aurait payé pour ça alors je ne dis pas
qu'elle a payé mais je connais
personnellement des gens qui payent pour
ça ne pas vous mentir ça existe ça
existe fait flipper dans ça existe mais
je vous le dis vraiment ça existe a
compris ça marquerait donc calé qualité
quelles étaient les pratiques qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait
expliquer à nos téléspectateurs quels
sont les victimes et qu'est ce qu'elle
faisait autour des victimes alors vous
allez voir quelqu'un vous payez sur
plusieurs séances et sept personnes au
moyen de sorts de sortilèges c'est pour
ça qu'on appelle sa sorcière va entrer
dans la vie de la victime va inciter la
victime à s'autodétruire en lui faisant
rompre avec son entourage en lui faisant
faire des bêtises en lui faisant faire
de mauvais placements financiers on
prend le pas on prend lé influence sur
la personne et en plusieurs séances
je connais des gens qui ont été victimes
de sa y compris dans le milieu de la
télé voilà l or après souvent quand on
dit ça on dit c'est surréaliste et et
et moi je vous avoue que personnellement
j'ai été victime d'une tentative
d'accord mais alors guillaume genton est
ce que vous pouvez public et aux
téléspectateurs ce qu'elle a fait est ce
qu'elle a demandé moi j'ai contacté
milla jasmin dont qui est l'une des
stars des marseillais versus le reste du
monde qui m'a donné sa version des faits
en fait car là il serait allé voir une
voyante dès l'âge de 18 ans fait elle
avait rappel c'était d'être célèbre et
donc de faire cette émission
les marseillais d'accord c'est de voir
cette voyante à exaucer son rêve puisque
on l'a retrouvé dans l'émission et suite
à sa carla s'est dit bon ben je peux
demander n'importe quoi cette voyante
elle lui aurait demandé de faire des
choses très graves à l'encontre de son
entourage
j'ai une liste n'y a eu ni circuler de
toutes les choses qui leur est demandé
bassett voyante séparation manon julien
qui sont soit disant dieu a mis d'accord
l'union de carla et kevin restera à
jamais dans la paix et sans tromperie
dont il ya tout un tas de sous et autour
de son compagnon qui est kevin quel
local qui ne la trompe jamais qu elle
reste supérieure à lui et c'est que la
prod des marseillais soit aux ordres de
carla donc elle se considère un peu
comme une star du programme et la prod
devrait obéir à ce qu'elle souhaite que
carl achète une maison voilà y'a plein
de choses pour elle il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont très durs envers son
entourage
elle avait notamment souhaité que deux
candidats notamment manon et julien ne
fasse plus les marseillais ne soient
plus les stars des marseillais et ce qui
s'est passé ce qui fait un peu peur à
tout le monde sait qu'ils ont rattrapé
le coup vite juste avant le début du
tournage que ça voilà ce à quoi histoire
son âge alors tu as très bien relaté
mais pire que ça c'est que julien
antilles dans des story qui l'a fait
très récemment laissent sous-entendre
que carla aurait souhaité des
malformations et le malheur aux enfants
aux bébés de certains couples mariés on
sait gré eu un baby boom et ce qui est
très étonnant alors je dis pas que c'est
vrai que c'est dû à la sorcellerie ou
pas mais c'est impossible de ne pas
passer à côté cette corrélation
quand on voit que jessica et thibault
ont connu l'enfer à la naissance de
maiden parce qu'il avait un problème à
l'oesophage il a été opéré à l'âge de 3
ans manon et julien qui ont eu de
nombreux problèmes de santé avec
angelina leur dernière née qui ne
gardait pas le lait est donc il ne
prenait pas de poids ça les annales en
préoccuper de liam sa fille quinquis
melao l'arrivée voilà c'est normal sur
les réseaux sociaux on voit toutes ses
forces avec un truc de fou sur les
réseaux sociaux dans les vidéos que qu'à
partager
marc batta sur les rayons ma boîte à
docs et d'anciens candidats de tayrac
expliquez-nous qui est marc batta parce
que c'est un blogueur ex candidate et
l'arrêté c'est lui qui a sorti la sphère
alors marc platt avait participé à la
belle et ses princes et le corps et
curseur des princes et des princesses de
l'amour anciennement les princes de
l'amour baglan qui paie dia et donc
c'est lui qui a sorti
c'est comme commencer comment il a pu se
procurer du tout c'est sonore etc
alors moi j'ai enquêté au niveau de la
médium notamment qui s'appelle dana et
je ne connais pas cette personne je le
tiens à vous seriez ressasser président
non ça c'est la wii est donc mais dans
le dans ce cadre de l' enquête pour
venir ici
j'ai posé la question faut savoir que
cette personne cette médium m'a parlé de
façon générale parce qu'elle a le secret
professionnel elle m'a dit je ne peux
pas accuser une personne vous dire que
j'ai reçu une personne mais ce que je
peux te dire c'est que à aucun moment je
ne suis responsable de ce qui s'est
passé c'est pas moi qui ai envie elle me
parle d'une histoire de deux pièces sur
le téléphone portable qui a dû être
sécurisés sur une clé usb par une
personne de confiance qui en fait ne
l'était pas et c'est comme ça qu'elle
pourrait expliquer la fuite alors dans
les vidéos qu'à partager marque blatak
on va avoir avec nous dans un instant on
découvre notamment deux séances de
sorcellerie sorcellerie impliquant des
poupées vaudou dans laquelle une voyante
exécute un rituel pour s'en prendre à
deux autres candidates de télé réalité
regarder ces deux vidéos en premier je
suis petit mais vain pour que maeva qui
était terriblement w9 et la production
et se fasse virer de monde hier et
devront se séparer de maeva rapidement
et instantanément et que car l'art de
vienne et vienne à tout jamais la
première des candidates de télé sera
viré nouveau tournage mais font la même
blessure par jour alors je sais pas qui
dit vrai qu'il faut c'est vrai c'est
vous mais il faut quand même être des
barges vous allez voir la réaction du
père mais un quart la mort ou dans un
instant on a il a fait une vidéo et vous
allez voir c'est complètement fou oui
tiffany avant qu'on accueille marc will
atteint très rapidement il faut savoir
que si carla ne réagit pas en ce moment
c'est qu'il ya une enquête en cours
désormais contre la voyante puisque
visiblement carla moreau aurait dépensé
entre un million de mots à main trois
cent mille euros
j'ai ça depuis 2010 ils sont dépassés
localement et lentement
elle a reconnu que c'était bien elle les
vocaux que l'on peut entendre et les
marseillais effectivement sont très en
colère après elle parce que justement
elle a souhaité du mal aux enfants et on
l'entend vraiment dire ça dans les
vidéos parler aujourd'hui
alors que c'était sa meilleure amie faut
savoir qu'à son ami à l'écran mais aussi
meilleure amie dans la vie est
aujourd'hui mais ils valent malgré ça ne
lui portent aucune rancoeur et dit
qu'elle est malade psychologiquement
roland perez que avant qu'on ait eu le
blogueur élections ni date erick aybar
glatt avec morphée style et vous allez
voir la réaction du père de carla c'est
complètement fou est ce qu'on risque
quelque chose à faire ça alors oui bien
sûr bien sûr quand on sait si ces faits
sont avérés c'est ces vidéos existent
vraiment si on reconnaît la voix de la
personne qui a commandé la priorité ceux
ci l'a reconnu elle l'a dit et elle se
défend en disant qu'elle a été rackettés
par cette voyante les inondations et de
défense défend comme ça désormais en
fait on aurait on aurait dans ce dans ce
type de biens sociaux dans ce type de
dossier en avant finalement de victimes
la victime envoûté qui a été par des
manoeuvres frauduleuses amenés à payer
certaines sommes parce qu'elle a cru
véritablement au sort qui pourrait être
donnée à certaines personnes
et puis à 6-6 elle aussi celle qui est
l'objet ceux et celles qui sont l'objet
de ces sorts qui a posteriori peuvent
subir ce qu'on appelle un préjudice
d'anxiété c'est à dire penser que tout
ce qui leur est arrivé aujourd'hui de
mal vient probablement de cette voyante
instrumentaliser à croire une candidate
une autre candidate de télé-réalité donc
oui tout cela peut donner lieu soit un
procès pénal à la fois pour escroquerie
abus de confiance abus de faiblesse et
ça ce serait peut-être la personne qui
aurait été à l'origine de cette demande
de sorts et puis il ya l'autre la l'hôte
les autres victimes
les parents d'enfants ceux qui
participent effectivement à ce jeu de
télé réalité et dont on peut penser que
tout ce qui leur est arrivé le mal peut
être à l'origine de l'essor qu'ils ont
été bons qui sont ici alors on a en a
marre glatt avec nous qui est en face
time we est très vite sinon je voulais
dire c'est important il ya une
instruction qui en cours en ce moment à
marseille il ya une enquête pour
rechercher la culpabilité pour chercher
les preuves
il faut juste rappeler c'est important
de le dire que ce soit vrai ou pas carla
est une personne humaine est une femme
et une mère de famille aussi c'est donc
c'est pas pu même être pas non plus
faire mal
manon s'il vous plaît on a on a valu
bonsoir à tous merci d'être la marque
comment ça va ben écoute jamais ça va
super et vous alors très bien marc platt
a alors c'est vous qui avez sorti cette
affaire on a du mal ay croire c'est
incroyable une histoire comme ça on se
dit mais dans quel monde on vit
j'ai dit exactement les choses lorsque
j'ai reçu les pièces à conviction après
je vais pas m'exprimer comme ça parce
que c'est pour mon travail je vois
policiers commencent à se presser dans
les allées reçu marque enfin un petit
peu connu sur les réseaux sociaux
je sais d'ailleurs t'as fait dévier les
vidéos sur moi qui m'ont quand même je
te le dire ben tu vois c'est que t'es
bonne foi parce que tu m'as que les gens
disent oh bah oui mais je sais qu'à un
moment j'ai pour ça donc on en parlera
ensemble t'inquiète pas tu vois comme ça
au moins on se dit tous marre tu vois
pas te dire si je regarde ta vidéo hein
ça fait c'était il ya deux internet et
des vidéos et ça va j'ai des gros
crucifix sur yann moix très attention
d'accord avec très bas très bas tu me
diras marque alors non mais c'est vrai
que cette histoire on se dit c'est c'est
fou comment comment on peut faire ça
alors toi toi tu reçois les trucs et
étudie quoi mois après mois étant quand
même père de trois enfants j'essaie
d'être un minimum pédagogue sur les
réseaux sociaux
tu vois je sais que vont il ya pas mal
de deux personnages pensent que la
personne n'a plus la plus appropriée a
parlé aujourd'hui autour de cette table
de ce que j'ai pu voir c'est benjamin
castaldi qui est un animateur de télé
réalité qui a qui a été plus eux-mêmes
psychologue quelques animateurs parce
qu'à un moment donné vous avez passé un
petit portrait juste avant avant cette
séquence de loana qui a été une égérie
nikon aujourd'hui on passait hors d'elle
pour tâche et quand on voit que par
respect je peux pas me dire sa petite
descente aux enfers mais ça va pas très
bien et sait on peut se poser des
questions et aujourd'hui je pense que la
corrélation avec ce sujet est de mise
parce qu'aujourd'hui on à carla qui est
une candidate de télé-réalité qui a
gravi les échelons comme elle le dit
elle même ou en tout cas ça a été
corroboré l'arrière il ya quelques
secondes sur votre plateau de l'âge de
18 ans elle a eu appel à la faim appelle
pardon la sorcellerie que sais je sais
c'est quoi cette histoire dense axel
rioux
c'est quoi donc vaudou il paraît qu'il
ya des trucs beaucoup plus grave
remarque que ce qu'on a vu comme les
trublions qui a des trucs sur les gens
font etc
ou alors j'ai eu ton rédac'chef par
pudeur et par respect de certaines
personnes
me sont proches je ne ne posterai pas ce
genre de choses bravo donc voilà et
excusez moi si je voulais aussi touché
deux trois mots par rapport à carla
justement je suis plus je crois que
c'est ça me dira qu'il le disait
vraiment pas s'acharner sur elle au
gardien c'est quelqu'un qui a fait ses
propres décisions qui en assume les
conséquences en tout cas je l'espère
parce qu'elle n'a pas daigné le fait que
ce soit c'est audio savoie qui a été
reportée sur mes réseaux sociaux j'en
prends l'entière responsabilité
effectivement maintenant moi je fais
juste que de donner l'information je
prends pas parti je ne suis pas là pour
bien évidemment tirer sur l'ambulance
comme on dit et cetera je fais juste mon
travail entre guillemets et aux
blogueurs simplement
alors il nous avait également fourni en
exclusivité une vidéo est ce qu'on
voulait qu'on la met dans laquelle carla
moreau aurait recours à une voyante pour
exécuter un rite contre un autre
candidat benjamin voilà c'est fait c'est
qui bouge à maghazi un candidat c'est un
magazine ses protecteurs exactement ses
producteurs - tu veux combattre cette
vidéo pas oui oui c'est toi qui déchira
le regarder regardez alors tous les
garder une place avec loana elle sert
mais non mais je ne sais pas gentil ça
marche
toi est ce que tu te rends compte aussi
marque alors là est ce que tu es sûr que
c'est bien car la caf et ses vidéos
enfin dans les sonore etc est ce que tu
es sûr en fait le problème c'est que
effectivement j'ai eu écho de cette
histoire de racket qui est venu armé
aurait évidemment dès lors où j'ai
commencé à parler de cette fameuse
histoire de sorcellerie
donc maintenant en fait j'ai vraiment
envie d'y aller à tâtons à ces artistes
rares et donc c'est tout et n'importe
quoi ce que j'ai posté ont été suivis de
notes qui ont appuyé les vidéos par
exemple les vidéos in my back et où le
travail comme elles le prétendent entre
guillemets a été effectué sur maeva s'en
est suivie de notes vocales qui appuient
et qui dit qu'en gros cette demande
vient bien d'elle maintenant il ya
certaines vidéos que j'ai où il n'y a
peut-être pas lo jo où il ya peut-être
l'odieux qui s'était jamais vraiment
c'est assez délicat marge est récent et
c'est donc marc justement marc voyer là
il est beaucoup plus prudent ce soir et
voilà parce que la version donc de maeva
c'est qu'elle est
vim on va rappeler est la version ça me
dira de maeva qui dit qu'elle est
victime de chantage de carla d'aubière
laquelle il exact mais sarah qui dit
qu'elle et ses voiles apparemment au
travers de kevin au travers de toi son
mari hank et de ta femme également à des
vous l'avait relaté sur vos réseaux
sociaux qui dirait qu'elle est victime
de chantage de raquette
il ya deux solutions si c'est le cas si
elle se fait racketter si elle a fait
des virements malgré elle c'est très
grave
c'est très grave à qu'on peut se poser
la question se demander comment pendant
autant de temps autant d'années
surtout qu'elle a un caractère bien
affirmé je le sais pour l'avoir vu en
conférence de presse
mais pour le coup si c'est elle qui est
à l'origine de ces troubles a rejoint
une marque
excuse moi simple si c'était faux je
pense que je fais suffisamment bien on
travaille avec la prochaine youtube plus
tu as je pense que tu aurais été
contacté pour justement divulgué cette
vérité ou même à la ligne cyril
aujourd'hui alors que j'apprends
l'histoire depuis ce matin tu vois
j'apprends vraiment l'histoire j'ai
vraiment mieux à leur marque l'histoire
depuis ce matin marqués simplement qu'il
ya une instruction qui est en cours et
que temps c'est logique c'est légitime
donc on n'a pas la réponse finale et ben
un peu patraque ont gelé la république à
ckoi marque alors c'est quoi la version
largement inspiré peux pas me permettre
de te le dire la en direct mais j'ai là
je connais la dre histoire et j'ai des
notes vocales qui le coup s'il vous
plaît résumé de ce que je ressens
remarque c'est que tu croit la version
car là maintenant non c'est pas du tout
ce que je crois à ce que je crois c'est
tout simplement en un clic une
conduction des gens quand ils prétendent
s'est fait léser par certaines personnes
et c'est dans le secteur de la télé
réalité 2 raquettes est très fréquent
sera quelque chose qui m'est alors quand
on aborde ces sujets là je ne suis pas
choqué ses cris ont gelé nos marques
pour nous marier au débat raquette on
débarque c'est vrai que je connais pas
très bien la télé réalité je te dis
franchement c'est direct wallix et ses
courants de faire de nos raquettes dans
la téléralité courant c'est court on
sait que ces courants devrait pas se
mentir les gens télé réalité c'est un
peu comme des footballeurs de chez eux
avec un téléphone nous arrive à faire
vibrer les foules
c'est ça voilà qu'il faut se rendre
compte qu aujourd'hui sur sur un slap
shade de 24 heures vous remplissiez je
crois peut-être dix fois au stade de
france mais carey landwind si
aujourd'hui on peut être que 2 millions
de vues sur ta vidéo
aujourd'hui on se retrouve alors regarde
pas ce qu'ils effectuent et bien sûr
m'approche à lui parce qu'il est un peu
plus modéré
et je pense qu'il va nommer ont pris les
dangers marque marquis la ilaha illa il
arrêter ce truc je crois aujourd'hui et
c'est dit voilà ça mais quand même mon
fils est la vérité vas y si l'algérie
sait même pas de quoi on parle moi parce
que la terre elle était mais regardez ce
qu'a dit son papa le père de carla mais
regardez il tient des propos
hallucinants ils se désolidarisent
complètement de sa fille regard des
marques
sam et euros l'on regarde voilà c'est là
où sarkozy
l'affiché qu'elle de voyantes j'ai moi
ces chèques là c'est dégueulasse que tu
as fait c'est pour italie n'est pas
évident c'est pas bien ce que ce qui est
franchement c'est dégueulasse tu payes
appelles tu payes le coup aujourd'hui
voie d'accord pour nous voler est utile
au maire d'arras
je suis dégoûté 100 bêtes et tu fais tu
vas d'accueil qu'est aux ja qui tient
fait du mal à se dépêtrer de cette
semaine c'est donc le papa de cette
candidate de télé ralité qui réagit qui
se désolidarise complètement de sa fille